book Richard M Nixon why did you decide
to write this book it didn't really
decide to it came to me Paula column of
times books is the overall editor of
this series of books for the it's called
the American president series and the
idea is to have a compact book about
each president and presidency and so
Paul asked me to meet with him and I
said no more books I'm finished with
books and then he said I edit this
series oh how nice I said and I had
actually bought some of them because
they're very very good and he said but
would you be interested in doing Nixon
and I could not resist it says on the
cover Arthur Schlessinger general editor
and though mr. Schlesinger were
name-dropping here but we were dear
friends for quite many years and when
Paul told him he had he said I have to
get Arthur's approval and our Arthur
Schlessinger said to me I was kicking
myself why didn't I think of it
fortunately just before Arthur died a
couple of months ago he was able to read
the proofs and he was happy with the
book and I was happy that he was able to
read them and then he wrote me a
wonderful letter and I was able at the
last minute to dedicate the book to him
which I thought was only the right thing
to do why did you decide to do that
dedicated to him well this was the last
book in the series that he would have
had anything to do with really except
maybe some choices for some future books
and he was such an inspiration not just
to me but to and not just a historians
but I think students I mean I think I've
spent most of my life reviewing Arthur
Schlessinger and he was a very very dear
friend
so it was only right that I dedicate the
book to him let me read a little bit of
what she wrote and then ask you a
question asked by a reporter as he was
campaigning in New Hampshire in March
1968 if he had a secret plan for ending
the war in Vietnam
Nixon replied yes and said I have a plan
to end the war though Nixon himself
didn't actually use the term secret plan
it stuck with him to his annoyance Nixon
also said that he couldn't reveal the
plan for fear of undercutting the
president but there was no plan is this
a lesson for those running now and for
the 2008 candidacy and talking about
Iraq is there a lesson to learn here
well I think the lesson is don't say
that you know what you're going to do if
you don't know what you're going to do
Nixon had to really kind of invent it
when he became president one of the
things that came out to me I mean I had
written my first book was on Watergate
and and the impeachment process I think
that's one of the reasons they thought
of me to write this and I had covered
Nixon but I learned an awful lot in
going through the material on him an
astonishing amount and one of the things
that came out to me was how unprepared
Nixon was for the presidency he'd been
in the house he'd been in the Senate
he'd been vice president for eight years
but he wasn't substance substantively
prepared he chose his cabinet in a
higgledy-piggledy fashion he hadn't
given that any thought he didn't really
have programs in his head
and he started very slowly because he
had not thought any of these things
through I had thought here is a man
certainly who was prepared for the
presidency also he was strangely
indecisive I don't I didn't realize that
it took him a long time to make up
decision make up his mind about things
or he voiced a lot of it off to his
staff I think coming back to your
question of these candidates most of
them the major ones are saying I do have
a plan for Iraq get out this date get
out that date do this do the other so
it's a different time and what sets this
book apart from
the others that have been written about
Richard Nixon well I think in the last
generation and a half really since he
died there have been many books about
Nixon but the tendency the overwhelming
tendency has been to do a segment of
Nick Nixon or his presidency
Nixon's of domestic policy Nixon's
foreign policy a Watergate of course
this is a book about Nixon and it has
all of that as I said 150 pages and
compresses it but I really have Nixon
from birth to death in that space and I
really felt that by the time I in it
ended the book I was in Nixon's head I
really feel I understood him and first
he has been one of the most complicated
as well as controversial presidents in
our history I want to ask you about that
but first let's invite our viewers to
join in on this conversation Democrats
202 737 triple 0 to Republicans 202 737
triple 0 1 independence 202 6 to 8 0 to
0-5 you say you understood him what do
you understand about him now he was a
very tormented man and you can see the
seeds of what happened later from very
early in his life I concluded that Nixon
was an improbable president elected
under improbable circumstances and
though this seems harsh the evidence led
me to the conclusion that this was a man
who never should have been president he
was we threw around the term paranoia
about Nixon a lot but he actually his
traits meet the definition of a paranoid
personality that's in the psychiatric
manual of mental disorders and the
paranoid personality sees you know
opponents and it makes it was using the
term enemies a lot no you know we got
used to but think about it if presidents
seeing the opposition party or
intellectuals or
Jews or all sorts of people as enemies
they had the enemy's list we we joked
about it but it's not funny to pick out
individual citizens beside their an
enemy and use the tools of government
against them he he drank too much he
drank a lot on top of drinking he took a
medication called dilantin that's really
never been approved as a mood alter and
he got it not through a prescription but
he thought it would be apparently an
anti-anxiety drug the effect of dilantin
was to enhance the effects of drink of
alcohol slurred talking mental confusion
Nixon was drunk on the eve of the
invasion of Cambodia I mean that's one
of the many times he I ended up feeling
empathy for him because he was so
tormented but a man who goes into the
presidency and his first order of
business is to get the goods on his
enemies this started in February 1969 I
mean the month after he was sworn in you
have to have a lot of pause about
whether that is the kind of human being
who should be there our first call for
Elizabeth drew comes from Hyde Ville
Oregon on our line for independence good
morning good morning guys how are you
good morning go ahead you're on the air
I thank you mister um I'm net OSU and
I've written several Richard Nixon for
my class I was wondering you know about
all the residents that he had throughout
the state's San Clemente uh and I can't
even and somewhere else I can't remember
how it was true that when Richard Nixon
was sworn in isn't it Johnson told him
uh in the residence that contained the
death tolls and the campsite missing an
action list and he wounded yours thank
you
familiar with any of them I think there
were two questions in there the
residence is yes it he also had one in
Key Biscayne Florida next to his really
probably his only friend bebe rebozo
that was a very strange friendship but I
will move on about Nixon showing him the
actual documents with the figures I'm
not aware of that but any incoming
president gets briefed by the outgoing
President on foreign affairs and you
know Vietnam was obviously a very big
one Merritt Island Florida good morning
good morning Lisbon hello you're on the
air okay President Nixon compared to
George Bush was a saint
of living Saint he did not screw the
American people he screwed some of you
reporters individually too bad he was
good for the American people the
Washington Post did a no favors the
Democrats didn't do that that was a
lousy Washington folks but there would
be bacon heart and I'm a Democrat but
George Bush is so much worse my god
George Bush should being president what
let's race mixing up the sainthood okay
you've made your point caller any
comparisons that you can make after
writing this book between Nixon and what
happened in Vietnam and President Bush
and the situation in Iraq
I think the caller was talking more
broadly first of all let's get rid of
the canard that it was just reporters
that he was after in fact I was not on
any list
it was academic did you cover him oh
well why I think I knew about him just
about all my life but I certainly
covered his presidency from the from the
very beginning the I knew this would
come up the comparisons between bush and
Nixon it Nixon tried to this
oi the Constitution the Constitution was
seriously in danger then contempt for
the Congress for the courts he was
making up his own law as he went along
now people will say that Bush I've
written a piece back old power grab over
a year ago Bush is trying to accrue more
presidential power and that is
definitely true well some of it is
getting back presidential powers that
were removed for the presidency as a
result of Vietnam a lot of it like the
wireless wiretapping was done in the
name of the war on terror we can't
really compare the two very closely
because they were at very different
times we don't know what Nixon would
have done in the war on terror he
certainly wanted to have as much
presidential power as he could possibly
get away with the color may have also
been referring to there's a large body
of thought that Nixon was far more
progressive even liberal on domestic
policy than Bush well once again you
have to look at the context Nixon was
pre Ronald Reagan pre the real
conservative takeover of the party he
called himself a pragmatist and I think
he should be taken as a word at his word
I have a feeling that he would be quite
at home with the conservative majority
of Republican party and in some ways he
set that in motion why do you think he
should be taken at his word being called
a pragmatist because when you look at
what he did most of all just about
almost all this domestic legislation
that he's credited with originated in
the Democratic Congress and Nixon he was
faced with the Democratic Congress he
was at as I say it's very important to
understand he was in a different context
before the real onrush of the
conservatism
and his record shows I mean he he went
along with many many of the initiatives
from Congress but in many cases
reluctantly are trying to cut the funds
for now he did come up with this
sweeping Family Assistance Plan which
was cash payments instead of welfare and
it was quite a radical plan the only
thing is I found in Haldeman HR Bob
Haldeman his top aides Diaries that a
week or two later after he proposed that
Nixon told Haldeman make sure it doesn't
pass we can't afford it and when it
collapsed in the Congress that was the
end of it our next call comes from
Chicago on the Republican line good
morning yes good morning it's always
nice to hear from a bonafide Nixon hater
like miss drew a kind of a Washington
Post liberal it's interesting that mr.
Nixon carried 49 states in 1972 and the
only president that ever did that and
also when you're talking about
presidential misuse of power think about
Roosevelt's during World War two Truman
seizing the steel mills Johnson's misuse
the power this pale in comparison to
what Nixon did which is basically
covering up a little crime in the
Watergate so speak to that miss drew I
realize you're very biased and very anti
Nixon and pleased to admit it thank you
very much I'll admit to nothing and it's
quite easy to throw these terms around I
am known as a dispassionate and quite
fair journalist had a Democratic
president done the things that President
Bush is doing in his power grab or done
what Nixon did I had I would have been
just as critical so let's put the let's
put this terminology decide aside
covering up the little crime or the
little covering up of a crime Watergate
is often reduced to that and it's just a
mistaken understanding of Watergate was
it was a
was a result of a mentality that we have
all these I have I have all these
enemies and we need to have in private
intelligence on these people and we need
to use the instruments of government
against them for instance John Dean drew
up the famous enemies list it was not
just Washington Post Democrats
I don't know anybody post was even on it
but it would be intellectuals it was
democratic party functionaries the
mentality that was Watergate a you could
say it started in Nixon's early life he
had a few friends he was a loner he was
very suspicious of people it began in
February 69 as I've mentioned when he
told his aides to set up a private
investigator II unit within the White
House paid for by private contributions
to get the goods on people so they had
these gumshoes following Ted Kennedy
around you know 24 hours things like
that and there was a straight line from
February 69 through the whole thing it
was it permeated the way he governed it
cannot be reduced I mean some say
Watergate showed he was a criminal is a
criminal presidency that underestimates
two it was the gravity thing if I could
go on for just a second the thing that
struck me we we knew about it at the
time was that part of his efforts to
destroy enemies I put quotes around both
those words was to undermine and
interfere with the processes of the
opposition party I don't know that we've
had this in American history where they
systematically first they decided that
they didn't want to run against ed
muskie they prefer George McGovern and
by the way collar
I think Ronald Reagan beat Walter
Mondale in 49 states as well it's a
small list obviously
so they had people like if this been
Donald Segretti people you know describe
him as a prankster this was a big
operation where they would go in all
sorts of places and interrupt Democratic
Party events by these little tricks and
things they did I don't know if they
caused McGovern to defeat muskie that's
not the point the point is the
opposition party is fair game for
meddling in what they did the chairman
of the parties offices muskies top aide
their offices were raided documents
stolen so the break-in at the Watergate
is just one thing it's almost 35 years
ago now in a pattern I'll use a term
that I'm sure we'll get our call are
very upset but I said in the book having
thought about it
this whole business of undermining the
opposition party is a step on the road
to fascism that's the first thing you do
is you make sure you just do everything
you can to weaken or undermine or you
know render in effect of the opposition
party I'm not saying Nixon was a fascist
I'm just saying this this is an
incredibly disturbing period I don't
know if anything like it meet Colorado
and our line for Democrats you're next
hey it's nice to see you again I
remember seeing you on PBS quite a bit
and it's good good to see you I'm
looking at the current situation with
you know I remember the Nixon thing and
the impeachment and I look at the
current occupant in the White House and
I see the Dems kind of um being a bit
wimpy and I don't like it much as Adam
and I'm I'm really wondering you know
what's the political game here where
where's the courage and what are they
aiming for that they can't seem to stand
up to this guy I'll hang up and let you
reply offline well thank you for the
nice greeting you've put your finger on
something that's terribly important now
there is a lack of courage there's no
question about it
and I don't mean to keep referring to my
writings but the last article I wrote
for the New York Review of Books was
about Congress in Iraq and I said the
idea of courage is just about passe in
Washington now I think a big part of
this is the role of the political
consultants I think they've done a lot
to damage our political process if
people hired for a lot of money and they
almost always counseled caution don't
you know don't do this don't do that you
could lose we don't have these days a J
William Fulbright from Arkansas who
actually did put his Senate seat at risk
and conducted the first terry's that
really brought Vietnam to the attention
of the public there's a lot of fear
among the Democrats here and some of it
a lot of it's based on myth that
Democrats got really damaged by opposing
the Vietnam War well two years after
Nixon left office as you know that
Democrats won the presidency and won a
huge number of seats in the Congress
again they go by the myth when the vote
came to authorize the war that people
who had opposed the Gulf War the first
Gulf War under President Bush's father
which was successful it didn't take all
that long had been hurt politically
there's no record of that the only
person who may have is that Sam Nunn of
Georgia who was thinking of running for
president I felt that he could not I
don't know how far Sam to would have
gone anyway there is no record of
anybody losing a House or Senate seat
because they opposed the Gulf War but
this fear and this these myths are now
very strong within the Democratic Party
I think they've done a very poor job of
dealing with the president's talking
points they allowed him and the
Republicans to
make this issue this last issue of the
funding a question of funding the troops
supporting the troops and they were very
on the defensive the whole way there was
no question in the end they were going
to fund the war they were trying to push
the policy in a direction it may now be
going in because because of their
efforts but the Democrats didn't have
the wit or the courage or whatever to
say this is about giving Bush a blank
check to continue the war on his terms
I've I've never figured out why the
Democrats aren't very good at this but
they're not and they fall into the
context that the Republicans and
President Bush that Alexandria Virginia
on our line for Republicans good morning
hi miss drew is armed talk to you I'm
the first-time caller
this is to do with the Watergate
break-in I was across the street at the
Howard Johnson's motel when the fourth
floor I spent the night had to go
upstairs to turn the water off for the
swimming pool that's what what I did I
took care of their pulled as I was
coming out to door on the fourth floor
the door opened right across the hall
and I saw a reel-to-reel void mechanical
it looked like they were listening to
with tapes of a rock and roll but well
what it was was the burglars and mr.
Liddy came out of the door and then we
went up to the 7th floor and I went in
the room to turn the water off and he
wanted to know what the room was for
because he just worth now later in that
summer the lifeguards were having a
problem with these men who would come to
the pole on the rooftop with binoculars
and looked down on Watergate well I took
this to the owners mr. mrs. Landy and
told them and they said yes there are
the FBI is in the hotel they're doing an
investigation of drugs and Watergate
there were a number of people I saw that
summer from the White House come to
Howard Johnson's and mr. Liddy would
have squirt them out to show them and
the way I the way I remember is by the
shoes they wore the fancy expensive wing
tip shoes Alba's only 20 years old so
this is something I noticed and the way
that they were dressing well you're a
little piece of history here I've never
heard this before in our celebrity days
you could have been on the cover of all
sorts of magazines if they'd known about
this story I think that's fascinating I
think the important point to make about
the Watergate break-in the famous
Watergate break-in on June 17th 1972 was
it was by that time rather routine it
was no aberration I mentioned earlier
that Nixon had set up this group of
gumshoes paid for paid for by private
contributions in the White House after
the Pentagon Papers were leaked he told
Eric Minh he wanted an enhanced group or
another group to stop leaks and they
were thus called the plumbers a term
they were proud of the plumbers carried
out a number of operations they raided
the office of the psychiatrist of Daniel
Ellsberg who leaked the Pentagon Papers
now think of that that's a real breach
of the Fourth Amendment of against
searches and seizures of private people
in their private offices as it is they
weren't very confident there there were
no files in this doctor's office by the
time they got
into the Watergate into the offices on
June 17th this was their fourth attempt
they had tried twice before once they
ended up locked in a closet somewhere
off a dining room the second time they
couldn't get the lock open
they sent somebody to Miami to pick up
some better tools they got in again they
got in the office over a Memorial Day
that year they put taps on the phone of
the chairman of the party Larry O'Brien
and another staff person they took
pictures of documents and but the tap on
our Brian's phone didn't work
and when gordon Liddy took this material
to John Mitchell the chairman of the
campaign committee to re-elect the
president or creep as it was called John
Mitchell is is said to have said that's
junk I doubt that was the word he used
that's junk
go back and fix the tap and lady said
okay and thus the famous break-in and
then there were other operations or
Nixon talked about a wild when the start
a fire at Brookings and get some things
from a safe there which a plumber had
told them were there they weren't and in
some ways the plumbers were comic
because they were they were so such
bunglers but it was also very sinister
here's this private force breaking into
places it was it was a very scary idea
it is a very scary idea
Elizabeth drew is the is a political
correspondent with the New York Review
of Books thank you for your time this
morning we've run out of it good to have
you on this is the new book Richard M
Nixon that's a good luck to you thank
you very much I really enjoyed it that's
it for today's show we'll be back here
tomorrow morning at 7:00 a.m. Eastern
thank you for watching